c'est plus une position de principe
parce que il ya beaucoup trop de
certitudes
il serait déjà que les masques on sait
pas si tout le monde aura un masque il
ya aussi cette cacophonie sur la rentrée
scolaire attend toujours au sénat
protocoles de sécurité sanitaire de 75
recommandations mais c'est très très
compliqué pour les élus en place de
pouvoir qu'est cela donc voilà d'où
c'est parce que vous avez tous un que
même si on est dans un moment de
solidarité
tout le monde doit travailler pour faire
sortir le pays de cette situation
eh bien il faut aussi que romark notre
différence d'ailleurs on a fait sur le
plan de confinement mais en ce moment
depuis hier après midi
nous examinons au sénat la loi qui va
avec son demande beaucoup aujourd'hui au
maire d'ambarès fait pas élus locaux
c'est pour ça que nous souhaitons aussi
que on dégage leur responsabilité pénale
l'osce qui vont appliquer des directives
venues de l'état